The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
continues to surprise us with its wealth
of hidden secrets each new discovery
helps us better our understanding of its
massive world so to increase your
chances of survival we've compiled six
more handy tips you might not know
be wary there are potential spoilers
ahead if you enjoy this video like it
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more features on breath of the wild and
be sure to watch our previous videos and
all the things I wish I knew before I
started throughout your adventure you
often encounter gelatinous foes known as
choo-choos when you kill one it drops
choo choo jelly which doesn't do much
alone however if you hit one with an
elemental weapon or arrow you can change
its physical properties for example
shoot a choo-choo jelly with a fire
arrow and it will turn into a red
choo-choo jelly alternatively you can
drop 2 to jelly and freezing or burning
temperatures to change its element to
these special tutu jellies can be used
as handy environmental traps that you
can fool enemies into hitting which will
cause a small explosion that deals a
heavy dose of elemental damage
later on in your adventure he will
encounter silver versions of enemies
these pale skinned monsters are much
tougher than their lower ranked
counterparts so it's understandable if
you choose to avoid them but you're
missing out
silver enemies drop a lot of valuable
items when you defeat them
a silverback hablen for example drops a
hardy mix of items including the usual
blue cobbling horns and fangs as well as
valuable gems that you can't get from
weaker picaud leaves you're likely to go
through a few of your hard-earned
weapons trying to take down silver
enemies but they're valuable drops more
than make up for the effort it takes to
defeat them it can be overwhelming
exploring the Gerudo desert especially
if you don't have the tools and
equipment to deal with its blistering
heat while it's highly recommended to
consume a chilly elixir or equip armor
with heat resistance there are a couple
of interesting techniques you can
utilize to increase your chances of
survival you wouldn't think it but shape
can be a lifesaver if you're desperate
simply get under a rock and set up a
campfire and wait it out until the
weather gets cooler just make sure you
have the proper gear to deal with the
drop in temperature though if there's no
shade in sight and you're really
desperate you can always turn to any of
the deserts few bodies of water while
this technique helps to decrease your
body temperature it doesn't do so for
very long it's more of a last resort
than anything
the Thunder helm is a useful piece of
armor that gives you all the benefits of
a fully upgraded rubber armor suit in
addition it literally makes you immune
to lightning strikes with this
gold-plated helmet equipped you'll never
have to worry about thunderstorms or
electrical attacks ever again to earn
the Thunder helm complete every major
side quest in Gerudo town these can all
be found by talking to the town's
inhabitants once you've completed all
the side quests talk to read you insider
mansion and then she'll hand it over to
you dragon parts greatly enhanced the
effects of food and elixir recipes each
part type adds to the effect time of a
recipe but you'll want to focus
specifically on obtaining dragon horn
shards since they increase a recipe
effect timer to 30 minutes but where is
a good place to hunt dragon horn shards
easy head to the Rio last spring in the
Ferrand region before going stock up on
arrows and bring wood and Flint a fire
weapon is ideal if you have one also
shock-resistant armors or elixirs are a
must
anyway when you arrive make sure to
activate the shrine hidden inside the
nearby waterfall for future fast travel
next set up a campfire near Rio last
spring under this palm tree and wait out
until morning a dragon should emerge
from the water quickly take out your bow
and shoot at the dragon's horn a
successful shot will pop off a horn
shard for you to collect if one's not
enough simply relight your campfire and
repeat this process once you're
satisfied fast travel to a cooking pot
of your choice and throw in a dragon
horn shard along with ingredients from
your favorite recipe to get that sweet
half-hour bonus
a nifty way to heal yourself while
you're exploring Hyrule's mountainous
regions like Death Mountain or the
Hebrew mountains is jumping into their
hot springs the warm soothing waters
slowly heal you over time so take a
moment and sit back and relax and try to
think of the simpler times in your life
you know before you're defeated by a
calamity Ganon and all your friends died
which in turn caused the whole world to
be thrown into a state of doom and
uncertainty you know those times
ah refreshing isn't it what other cool
and useful mechanics have you found let
us know in the comments below and for
more coverage on the Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
[Music]